We can see here that the binomial we have is y minus z, which down here is going
to mean x minus 2. So that's what belongs in this first set of parantheses. Then
the trinomial is y squared which is x squared why don't you substitute in x,
plus y c which is really x times 2, but I'm going to write that as 2x. And then
plus z squared. Which is just plus 4. Awesome! I know it might feel a little bit
silly to find a factorization that's so much more complicated than the initial
expression. But once we talk more about higher order polynomials, you'll
understand what the importance of writing out factorizations like this is. I'll
give you a hint that we've already talked about. Each linear factor is showing
us an x-intercept of a graph. There's a ton of exciting stuff ahead. So just get
ready.